[Música]
en México el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador ha propuesto una reforma
que transformaría el sistema electoral
mexicano según el gobierno La idea es
hacerlo mucho más cercano al ciudadano
pero para la oposición dice que lo que
le permitiría es regresar el sistema
electoral a un control completo por
parte del gobierno Cuáles son los puntos
clave de esta reforma centralizar los
procesos electorales es decir se
eliminarían aquellas juntas electorales
que están en los diferentes estados
mexicanos también impulsar El voto
electrónico y el voto en el extranjero
reducir el financiamiento de los
partidos también modificar los procesos
de patrocinio de las propagandas de las
campañas también cambiar el umbral de
participación mínima para la revocación
de un mandato que pasaría a un mínimo de
33%. reducir a los números de senadores
plurinominales y también propone
desaparecer los diputados plurinominales
desaparecer o transforma digamos el INE
que es el Instituto Nacional electoral
para ser reemplazado por el Instituto
Nacional de elecciones y consultas
también propone que los consejeros
electorales sean elegidos por el pueblo
mexicano en voto abierto y pasar de
tener 11 a solamente tener 7 la
propuesta Pues nos gustó en una porción
de la población que salió a las calles
para manifestarse en contra el
presidente desestimó estas
multitudinarias manifestaciones en
diferentes ciudades mexicanas veamos
Andrés Manuel López Obrador salió a la
defensa de su reforma electoral que
levantó la polémica en México luego las
multitudinarias manifestaciones del
domingo el mandatario respondió
catalogandolas como racistas y clasistas
y calificando la escena como un
striptease político
Entonces lo de el INE fue una
excusa
una bandera los que se manifestaron ayer
lo hicieron en contra
de la transformación que se está
llevando en el país
la propuesta de López Obrador contiene
múltiples aristas que generan
controversia y despiertan acusaciones de
querer acaparar el poder la más
importante es la sustitución del
Instituto Nacional electoral y la
creación del instituto nacional de
elecciones y consultas un ente que
centralizaría toda la Organización de
las elecciones y le quitaría el control
al gobierno opositores acusan al
mandatario de creer acumular poder como
el caso del presidente de la cámara de
diputados Santiago Creel
las mexicanas y los mexicanos salimos a
las calles a defender nuestra democracia
levantamos la voz y dejamos muy claro
que no apoyaremos la de forma electoral
que propone el presidente México no es
de un solo hombre es de todas y todos
la reforma también apunta una reducción
de 200 diputados 32 senadores y que los
consejeros y jueces electorales se han
votados por el pueblo entre una lista de
candidatos confeccionada por el
presidente la Corte Suprema y El poder
legislativo por ahora el partido López
Obrador no tiene la mayoría
parlamentaria necesaria para que la
reforma avance pero se esperan intentos
para conseguir apoyo de legisladores de
otros partidos
el gobierno dice que reducir este
sistema electoral le permitiría ahorrar
muchísimo dinero y hacerlo mucho más
transparente Pero qué hay de la
eficiencia que ya ha ganado a lo largo
de estos años logrando consolidar una
forma de hacer los procesos electorales
en México algunos sectores dicen que lo
que busca es darle un mayor control al
sistema electoral al partido oficialista
otros aún más especulativos dicen que
permitiría que el presidente López
Obrador pueda pensar en extender su
permanencia en el poder también hay
muchas suspicacia en cuanto a la prisa
de querer lograr esta reforma rápido
inmediata cuando quedan solamente dos
años para las elecciones presidenciales
incluso hablan de intentar hacer la
reforma lo más rápido posible para
ensayarla o ensayar este nuevo sistema
electoral en las elecciones en el estado
de México que están previstas para el
2023 la controvertida reforma electoral
en México es nuestro tema de análisis
hoy en el debate de France 24 y para
conversar sobre este sistema hemos
invitado a Aleida a la vez ella es
diputada federal y Vice coordinadora del
grupo parlamentario de morena también
está con nosotros Santiago torreblanca
él es diputado del partido pan también
es secretario de la comisión de reforma
política electoral y miembro de la
comisión de puntos constitucionales les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación nuestros
televidentes también pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Facebook y también en instagram nos
encuentran como arroba el
debate_f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios numeral el debate f24 no
olviden también que todos los contenidos
están disponibles en podcast estamos en
Apple podcast en Spotify en deezer y en
TuneIn comienzan comienzo entonces
dándole la palabra a nuestra invitada a
leyda allí en la ciudad de México para
preguntarle cuál es la justificación del
gobierno para impulsar esta
una forma al sistema electoral mexicano
que está generando tanta controversia
allí en su país
un saludo muy afectuoso desde la Ciudad
de México y Bueno pues yo creo que a
partir de esta introducción que nos
haces cabe precisar que el Instituto
Nacional electoral que es un órgano
autónomo constitucionalmente en este
país y que rige las el los procesos
electorales no desaparece se mantiene su
autonomía constitucional y solo se le
modifican los procedimientos a nuestro
sistema electoral mexicano en ningún
momento hay una injerencia del poder
ejecutivo sobre el órgano autónomo y al
contrario lo que proponemos es
ciudadanizar aún más la toma de
decisiones y en este caso el que sea la
gente quien elija a quienes encabezan el
consejo general del Instituto Nacional
electoral una propuesta sustancial es
que a partir de una crisis económica tan
fuerte que vivimos a nivel mundial y
México no es la excepción también se
reduzcan los gastos que se hacen en este
instituto y por eso creemos necesario
readecuar el diseño de su estructura
para así No hacerla tan onerosa en el
gasto público y también desaparecer el
financiamiento de los partidos políticos
con esto estaríamos ahorrando anualmente
24 mil millones de pesos y eso es algo
que se requiere para rubros de otra
índole en nuestra
sociedad en en las en el país Pues
precisamente ahora que estamos dando
derechos en la Constitución como la
pensión universal adultos mayores que va
creciendo Por cierto lo que se le
entrega a cada persona de manera
bimestral para llegar a los 4.000 pesos
el siguiente año pues entonces que
podamos sí darle prioridad claro a que
la gente tenga también como enfrentar
esta crisis
vemos ahora Cuál es el punto de vista de
Santiago torrealba nuestro siguiente
invitado para conocer Cuál es su punto
de vista en este Punto de partida del
debate de Santiago Bienvenido al
programa y Por qué consideran ustedes
que esto es una reforma digamos
regresiva porque rechazar esta propuesta
viste lo que se trata es de tener todo
el poder por parte del ejecutivo y
pretender engañar a la gente a la
ciudadanía Y tratar de engañar al mundo
miren los consejeros electorales el día
de hoy Son electos por el Congreso de La
Unión por un acuerdo en común de todas
las fuerzas políticas se requieren dos
terceras partes lo cual garantiza que
aquellos jugadores en la cancha es decir
los partidos políticos estén de acuerdo
con su árbitro mañosamente dicen que
quieren que sean electos por la
ciudadanía lo que no dicen esa propuesta
de quién dicen que a propuesta del
titular del ejecutivo del Congreso que
hoy en día domina una fuerza política y
de la suprema corte de justicia de la
nación imagínense Qué pasaría si las
candidatas y candidatos al consejo
electoral resultan aquellos propuestos
por el ejecutivo
qué ciudadanización existiría al
respecto qué Independencia e
imparcialidad existirá un control total
del ejecutivo dicen que se trata de
ahorrar Pero cómo va a existir un ahorro
si existiría un proceso electoral
adicional es decir aparte de los
procesos electorales de diputaciones en
adurías presidente de la república
cargáramos la elección de presidentes y
magistrados del tribunal electoral
Haz es una idea pésima es un tema que se
ha discutido cuál debe ser la naturaleza
del poder judicial como un órgano por
ejemplo técnico especializado cuál debe
ser su método de elección desde
montesquiere incluso cuando se
conformaban los Estados Unidos de
Norteamérica en el federalista se deja
claro que la elección popular es el peor
método porque queda a las pasiones
populares del momento el arbitrio de las
decisiones en lugar de criterios de
justicia y técnica también desaparecen a
los organismos públicos locales
autónomos que para que conozcan nuestro
auditorio son los encargados de
organizar las elecciones en cada una de
las entidades dicen que esto va a
significar un ahorro pero no es cierto
porque esa labor se trasladaría a este
órgano con el cual quieren sustituir al
INE por cual a valores compensados
acabará haciendo lo mismo pero aquí Lo
importante el Instituto Nacional
electoral cuenta con un servicio
profesional de carrera
decir hay gente que por medio de
exámenes de oposición y ascenso conforme
américos está altamente especializado
quieren que esos órganos Únicamente se
conforman de manera temporal durante las
elecciones
es una laboral altamente técnica la
gente que se ha contratada por tres o
cuatro meses no va a tener el bagaje y
la experiencia de años pero aparte hacen
otras modificaciones Sí por ejemplo
el modelo de comunicación política
actualmente las y los funcionarios
públicos durante el tiempo las campañas
solo podemos pronunciarnos en temas que
tienen que ver con protección civil
salud e educación quiero emplearlo para
para que puedan hablar de cualquier
servicio público es decir que con el
dinero los impuestos puedan hacer
promoción personalizada lo cual
funciona y si quieres ahorita seguimos
hablando al respecto de temas lo triste
aquí es que la gente que apoya eso
engañada es decir gente que engañada por
quien Debería ser el primer mandatario
de la nación va al matadero como un
ganado aplaudiendo actores es muy triste
que eso pase una democracia Santiago Qué
hay de estos argumentos de el tema de
ahorro de la cantidad de dinero que se
ahorraría la institucionalidad mexicana
y que podrían destinar esos dineros a
otros proyectos Sobre todo como dice
nuestra otra invitada en un momento en
el que el país está en una crisis
económica como lo está buena parte del
planeta después de salir de la del
confinamiento por la pandemia Kobe 19 y
que son necesarios
buscarse otros recursos para garantizar
ciertas aspectos sociales de la sociedad
mexicana
mira en primer lugar no hay no hay
democracia más cara que la inexistente y
fíjense Venezuela o Corea del Norte Por
favor Y en segundo el ahorro sería
marginal porque repito si le sumamos el
costo que costaría elegir a los
magistrados del tribunal electoral a los
consejeros del INE tratamos Los costos
de los organismos locales al INE a
valores compensados sería muy muy muy
muy poco al ahorro sería marginal pero
aparte Aleida decía que serían 20.000
millones de pesos de ahorro por Dios
santo en construir una refinería en la
época de la transición energética les
está costando 100.000 pesos al año un
aeropuerto que no sirve para nada tiene
un sentido gubernamental de más de 20
mil pesos al año quieran ahorrar dejen
de gobernar con ideología y decirle los
recursos para lo que hace falta Claro
que hace falta programas sociales
sectorizados y focalizados en un país
donde el 50% de su población es pobre
pero no busquen el ahorro donde no
existe Claro en donde se necesita la
leyda retomamos la conexión con usted y
quisiera preguntarle sobre el momento en
el que se encuentra México a esta altura
en el 2022 está ya lo decía yo a un año
de las elecciones en el Estado de México
y a dos años de las elecciones
presidenciales es el momento para
impulsar un tipo de reforma como esta de
alto calibre en un sistema electoral
porque no esperar después de un proceso
y no estrenar el sistema electoral nuevo
en unas elecciones presidenciales porque
hacerlo ahora
porque estamos en un cambio de régimen
nosotros Así lo concebimos
no es solamente el que otro partido haya
llegado al gobierno es la izquierda en
este país la que llegó al gobierno y
estamos encargándonos de hacer todo un
andamiaje institucional en donde le
estamos regresando al estado mexicano
las facultades y funciones que por 30
años delegó a la iniciativa privada y
ahora creemos que es el estado mexicano
El que se debe hacer cargo de hacer
valer estos derechos de las y los
ciudadanos y nos falta la reforma
electoral ya avanzamos con mucha sobre
Derechos sociales y avanzamos con la
discusión sobre la soberanía energética
Lamentablemente ahí tampoco Contamos con
la oposición porque ellos solamente
pretenden hacer negocios a costa del
estado por eso no entienden esta visión
que nosotros tenemos de lo que es un
nuevo andamiaje jurídico y defunciones
de los diferentes poderes de este país
es necesaria es urgente estamos en una
crisis económica y yo creo que nada
Pueden decir quienes gobernaron durante
dos décadas en este país y no pudieron
ni construir una barda cuando hablaron
de una refinería ahora hablarnos de cómo
se está gastando el dinero actualmente
no tienen autoridad política para
hacerlo ojalá nos hubieran enseñado a
hacer las cosas pero tan no lo hicieron
bien que la gente dejó de confiar en
ellos y ahora están confiando más en
este proyecto que gobierna Andrés Manuel
López Obrador en el país y que viene
ganando a partir de la llegada de él a
la presidencia ya estamos gobernando 22
estados de 32 que componen el país
entonces la gente no está viendo mal
estas propuestas se está abocando a
respaldar que austeridad y que los
partidos políticos no tengan por qué
devengar
11.000 o 13 mil millones de pesos al año
que es lo que los del partidos de la
oposición quieren defender Y eso es lo
que no dicen ellos quieren seguir
viviendo a costa del erario en su vida
partidaria Cuando antes de la Reforma de
los ochentas no era así antes los
partidos no contaban con financiamiento
todo esto se fue acreditando porque la
oposición se lo demandaba a un gobierno
que cada vez era más insostenible que
eran los gobiernos del Pri entonces así
fue concedió el financiamiento a los
partidos políticos ahora nosotros
decimos no ya no se puede sostener más a
partidos políticos con gasto ordinario
se tiene que dejar solo para años
electorales a usted dice que cada vez
más personas más mexicanos apoyan esta
propuesta que llega con el presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador que hay
entonces de esas multitudinarias
manifestaciones que vivimos en Ciudad de
México y en otras ciudades mexicanas
donde una buena porción de la población
está en contra de esta reforma
finalmente ustedes son el gobierno no
solamente de quienes los apoyan de
quienes votaron por ustedes si no de
todos los mexicanos también hay que
escucharlos
Sí yo respeto todas las manifestaciones
que haya tan es así que por eso El poder
legislativo se conforma con una
proporcionalidad de lo que es la
apreciación y el respaldo de la gente a
las diferentes propuestas que hay y ahí
está la correlación en la cámara de
diputados en la cámara de senadores en
los gobiernos de los estados que es la
máxima que tenemos de una manifestación
de posturas de la gente a quienes están
respaldando y a quien no Es muy válido
que se haya hecho esta manifestación lo
que no es válido es que lo hagan con
base en mentiras en decir que va a
desaparecer el INE que pierde su
autonomía que van a elegir ahora el
poder ejecutivo esa es una mentira yo
creo que mucha gente fue llamada a
partir de la mentira y esto es lo que
hay que aclarar que el INE no desaparece
sigue siendo autónomo lo que estamos
proponiendo es eliminar el
financiamiento a los partidos políticos
a desaparecer estructuras del INE que
son innecesarias como los organismos
públicos locales y que con esto
ahorremos dinero y hagamos
procedimientos
democráticos más sencillos menos
rebuscados que son derivados de la
historia de desconfianza que hay en los
institutos que llevan las elecciones en
los procesos electorales que son
amañados hay fraudes electorales hemos
sido presa de eso tenemos esa
preocupación también pero no queremos
que siga siendo un gasto tan oneroso
porque no estamos coincidiendo con que
gastar mucho dinero en la democracia
implique que sean procesos con certeza
con esta credibilidad
esposas con más austeridad le doy la
palabra ahora a Santiago su opinión
sobre esta coyuntura que esta reforma
llegue justamente dos años antes de las
elecciones presidenciales se haga todo
este nuevo andamiaje de una reforma
electoral en el país y
las manifestaciones que llamaron mucho
la atención porque fueron masivas sobre
todo allí en el centro de la capital
mexicana veíamos el ángel de la
independencia completamente rodeado por
personas rechazando esta propuesta del
gobierno
sí mira a ver las reformas electorales
han surgido de dos formas o como un
reclamo desde la oposición o cuando
vivíamos en un régimen autoritario como
válvulas de
despresurización del gobierno
recordamos la la reforma de reyes
heroles que permitió que hubiera
representación proporcional Bueno una
válvula de escape para que el gobierno
unitario y no democrático pudiera tener
esas válvulas y y y y la ciudadela no
explotará o el otro gran momento de
reformas fueron desde la oposición con
exigencias en las que participó la
izquierda para pedir que se limitara El
poder del ejecutivo para influir en la
contienda la idea decía que antes de los
80 no recibían los partidos
financiamiento Pues claro que no pero
tampoco había democracia tampoco quería
división de poderes todo era organizado
desde el estado los partidos requieren
dinero público porque donde no lo
reciben lo reciben o de empresas que
imponen sus intereses
o del crimen organizado su peor aún o de
instituciones del extranjero lo cual
pierden autonomía e Independencia y
aparte el partido mayoritario
especialmente en el supuesto de que no
sea un país honesto y desgraciadamente
México es un país corrupto se va a
desviar recurso público para fines
particulares partidistas y a los
partidos pequeños les va a quedar de dos
sopas Si eso pasara o recurrir al Gran
capital o recurrir al crimen o tener que
doblegarse al poder lo cual
evidentemente no nos convendría pero
también
mienten dicen que quieren desaparecer a
los diputados plurinominales cuando la
iniciativa no dice eso de iniciativa lo
que plantea es que el 100% a los
diputados y el 100% de la senadoras y
senadores siempre iluminales buscan
reducir su número dicen que somos muchas
y muchos diputados a ver para un país de
más de ciento de 20 millones de personas
somos 500 diputados campeonarte un
ejemplo en Francia tiene una población
de de 76 millones y tienen 577 diputados
por qué a mayor democracia hace falta
mayor pluralidad y si nuestro nuestro
sistema electoral es rebuscado sí
quieren un procedimiento electoral
simple volteen a ver a Nicaragua eso es
un proceso electoral simple donde el
partido en el poder tiene el 100% de los
triunfos electorales la democracia
cuesta pero la falta de democracia
cuesta mucho más cara Sí Santiago usted
menciona que estos tipos de pedidos por
parte de la oposición a lo largo de la
historia y también de la población han
sido para despresurizar un poco los
sistemas o para hacer reclamos al
gobierno Pero estas manifestaciones que
han sido bastante llamativas por parte
de la comunidad internacional ha llamado
mucho la atención ver a tantos mexicanos
en las calles este fin de semana
pidiendo que se respete este entidad
electoral mexicana es completamente lo
opuesto están pidiendo que se mantenga
Una institución
que ha funcionado bien que ha dado
buenos resultados desde el punto de
vista de los ciudadanos cambia entonces
completamente la visión del pedido
ciudadano Así es A ver nos gustó a ver
Construir la democracia en México por lo
menos la democracia electoral nos ha
costado más de 50 años y ha sido una
lucha histórica en la que hemos
participado izquierdas y derechos de
manera unida porque tenemos un frente
común democratizar al país la ciudadanía
se da cuenta de que está funcionando
entonces apoya mayoritariamente hay que
recordar que el sistema
democrático electoral mexicano es
ejemplo internacional
países de los llamados primer mundo
países desarrollados voltean a ver a
link y preguntan cómo funciona nuestra
legislación para copiar el modelo eso
demuestra la fortaleza el desarrollo
jurisprudencial el desarrollo
institucional que tiene para hacer
ejemplo de países que en muchos otros
casos son más desarrollados que México
su opinión Aleida
yo vuelvo a insistir con violine no
desaparece
Qué bueno que aquí el pan
a nombre en el diputado torreblanca
reconoce que no no están dispuestos a
eliminar el financiamiento a los
partidos políticos porque ya van
entonces enunciando con más
transparencia Cuál es realmente lo que
están defendiendo y están defendiendo
esos privilegios de los que ya es
imposible gozar en estos tiempos de
crisis económica estamos hablando de que
los partidos políticos Aunque aquí no lo
no lo quedamos reconocer si viven de
financiamiento privado y hay que
regularlo hay que regularlo bien y hay
que ver cómo se hacen aportaciones de
militantes sin que esto de Pauta a que
sean de otros orígenes el que haya
financiamientos como a quien lo acaba de
reconocer hasta internacionales que
incidan en la vida pública de un partido
político pero nosotros sostenemos el que
sí desaparecer el financiamiento a los
partidos políticos no podemos tener una
democracia sustentada en que solamente
recibiendo dinero de los del erario es
como podamos tener procesos
transparentes o sin injerencia alguna
ellos pues son los hacedores de estas
reglas tan engorrosas de una democracia
burocrática que tenemos en el país que
efectivamente nos ha costado y que hemos
tratado de
enderezar en los procesos para
seleccionar a diputados senadores que
por cierto el diputado torreblanca
insiste en decir que son todos
plurinominales Es la falta de
entendimiento a lo que es la democracia
pura Y esto es ya no va a haber listas
de partidos políticos para que en esas
listas entren diputados que nadie conoce
y nadie eligió sino se hará una
presentación por partido político eso es
lo que estamos proponiendo en cada
entidad federativa o sea en cada estado
que compone esta república para que sean
las personas las que a partir de esas
listas establezcan primero a Qué partido
apoyan Y en segundo lugar a qué persona
y eso no tiene nada que ver con las
listas plurinominales Entonces yo creo
que la oposición se encarga de mentir de
descalificar de señalar que esta es una
reforma regresiva cuando en realidad lo
que están queriendo
sostener son sus privilegios en estas
prerrogativas a los partidos políticos
en esta decisión de que los consejeros
del INE los ponga la cámara de diputados
y no las personas de manera directa en
un voto directo popular Y por qué no
hacernos de esta experiencia porque no
podemos estar repitiendo modelos de otro
tipo cuando tenemos que ya a realizarnos
a un modelo propio de nuestro país
y experiencias en todos
de escala internacional Pero más bien
con esta historia que tenemos como
México que que ha sido un sistema
electoral Lamentablemente muy engorroso
Santiago desde la oposición claramente
el partido de gobierno y la propuesta
del presidente pues ya tiene un Norte
muy claro el 23 de noviembre se espera
que sea presentado este plan a las
comisiones y que el día 28 sea discutido
qué van a hacer entonces
desde la oposición Qué plan tienen esto
también significaría una posible Unión
de las diferentes fuerzas opositoras
allí en México para hacerle contrapeso
hasta propuesta del presidente
Así es toda la oposición y la gente de
bien nos estamos uniendo para defender
nuestras instituciones democráticas es
necesario Y la verdad duele mucho la
mentira a ver a nivel internacional hay
dos formas de elegir a las diputaciones
Hola la mayoría relativa es decir en un
Distrito circunscripción gana una
persona o por un sistema de listas que
es representación proporcional llamados
prenominales doy lectura a la iniciativa
del presidente dice la cámara de
diputados estará integrada por 300
diputadas y diputadas que serán elegidos
mediante el sistema de listas votadas en
cada una de las entidades federativas es
decir
plurinominales
pretenden ganar el aplauso popular con
mentiras es lo que no se debe tolerar es
lo que no podemos traer como país que El
Ejecutivo y el legislativo de un partido
mientan mientan a diario
molesta molesta y entristece y
entristece más que haya gente buena que
les crea
Aleida algo que decir
hemos sido siempre muy responsables no
nos basamos en las mentiras es muy
lamentable que haya que discutir con
diputados que no entienden lo que es un
proceso de representación proporcional y
los procesos de democracia pura porque
el no entenderlos hace que manejen así
las cosas y que tergiversen todo a la
gente que convocan a movilizarse cuando
lo hacen También basándose en la mentira
que implica desaparecer al INE el INE no
desaparece el INE mantiene su autonomía
constitucional esto lo que estamos
desapareciendo son los privilegios y
esos es a los que ellos están abocados a
meter el financiamiento público a
partidos políticos el que decidan los
consejeros la clase política y no la
gente el que sigamos en una lógica de
Procedimientos engorrosos en los
procesos electorales y gastando mucho
dinero en los poderes educativos Aleida
le preguntó el presidente de los
mexicanos ha dicho que hay un plan b con
el que están trabajando de manera
paralela a esta propuesta que se le está
haciendo a los mexicanos y que esto
incluye pues una serie de reformas a las
leyes secundarias electorales que podría
ser votado Entonces el 7 de diciembre
aquí hay mucho temor que con esa
necesidad o ganas del gobierno de llevar
esta propuesta a buen Puerto y que sea
aprobada se haga algunas aproximaciones
como esas reformas a esas leyes
secundarias que también genera mucha
incertidumbre y un poco de suspicacia
por parte de otros sectores políticos
que se puede decir al respecto
que hoy estamos actuando de manera
transparente y responsable y abierta
esta discusión ya la dimos en un
parlamento abierto que son foros en
donde se invita académicos especialistas
a partidos políticos a los mismos
funcionarios del INE que en ningún
momento expusieron una verdadera contra
propuesta a esta reforma constitucional
que envió el presidente de la república
querían hasta anularle su derecho a
presentar iniciativas el claro
desconocimiento del pan a eso llevó en
la junta de coordinación política que el
coordinador dijera que no tiene derecho
el presidente de presentar iniciativas
es una forma muy burda de actuar con
odio con esta animadversión tan
ciega que tienen con el presidente Y
entonces anular con ello la posibilidad
real de concretar una reforma
constitucional nosotros los hemos
invitado de manera franca abierta de
frente a que este esta discusión la
hagamos con la búsqueda de un sistema
electoral que merece México pero si se
niegan a hacerlo pues obviamente También
tenemos el derecho de establecer una
propuesta secundaria que rescate los
procedimientos que estamos proponiendo
Santiago qué decir al respecto sobre
estas leyes secundarias que podría ser
ese plan B del presidente López Obrador
primero aclarar no es odio a morena es
amor a México en primer lugar en segundo
esas pues no conocemos el contenido de
esa iniciativa pero si pretenden copiar
la la pretendía reforma constitucional a
leyes secundarias la misma va a resultar
inconstitucional y en México hay
división de poderes y ya sea la suprema
corte de justicia de la nación ya sea el
tribunal electoral del poder judicial de
la Federación
declarean inconstitucionales dichas
leyes y por lo tanto quedan expulsadas
del orden jurídico mexicano ha
trascendido que lo que buscan
escultores de fiscalización al INE
recordamos que el INE no solo
organizaciones Fiscales a los recursos
públicos y privados de los partidos para
verificar que si usen para los fines
para los que fueron otorgados que el
origen de eso sea lícito y conocido y
evitar fraudes con eso Adivinen Quién es
el partido más multado Por recibir
recursos ilícitos y por utilizarlo para
fines distintos a los estipulados en la
ley morena por eso quieren debilitar al
Instituto Nacional electoral para que no
los pueda seguir multando por violar la
ley y para usar el recurso de los
impuestos para otros fines o engañar a
la gente como lo hicieron constituyeron
un fideicomiso supuestamente para ayudar
a los damnificados y lo que hicieron fue
recargar dinero Público de personas
desconocidas lo cual está prohibido para
fines partidistas entonces bueno
tengamos cuidado la verdadera pretensión
de morena es debilitar cualquier
institución democrática Como lo hicieron
con la Comisión Nacional de Derechos
Humanos poniendo una fila Como lo
hicieron con la Comisión Federal de
competencia económica Como lo hicieron
como la comisión reguladora de energía
sí cualquier institución del país la
quieren desaparecer para regresar a un
poder unipersonal y eso no es odio a
morena es amor a México y a las
instituciones que nos ha costado tanto
trabajo construir Ojalá la gente que de
buena fe confíen ese proyecto Abra los
ojos Santiago y se dé cuenta que ha sido
engañada y el fin de esas de esas
modificaciones sería cual permanecer en
el poder que Andrés Manuel López Obrador
permanezca como presidente yo no creo
que sea eso más bien lo que pretenden es
que su sistema de pensamiento
permanezca en el poder sí que exista un
control constitucional y un control
democrático de esas decisiones Aleida
qué se puede decir de sobre esa
declaración
es totalmente aberrante Escuchar estas
palabras que finalmente no no se abocan
a entender la iniciativa del presidente
si desaparece la fiscalización pues es
porque desaparece el financiamiento
público a los partidos políticos que vas
a fiscalizar si no hay financiamiento
pero ahí es donde está esa forma de
tergiversar la discusión y de no decir
con Claridad y transparencia
públicamente que no quieren que
desaparezca el financiamiento público a
los partidos políticos nosotros estamos
sosteniendo que sí porque además también
aunque no lo queramos reconocer que eso
es algo totalmente insensato y amoral
hablando Pues de estas personas o gentes
de bien de la de lo que se refiere el
diputado del pan que no reconozcan que
hay financiamiento privado y que más
bien necesitamos regularlo y decir como
si funcionaría Y entonces el que no
tenga controles el poder ejecutivo
mentira
Claro que se mantiene el control del INE
de manera Autónoma es un órgano que
nació a partir de toda nuestra historia
lamentable de fraude tras fraude en las
elecciones y lo estamos manteniendo así
no mientan es es como me preocupa que
parece parezca esto un diálogo de sordos
porque no se abocan ni quiere la
oposición verdaderamente escuchar que
propone esta iniciativa en un nuevo
sistema político y nunca ellos Proponen
una alternativa quieren quedarse
y con los gastos actuales que son
insostenibles en el país Aleida Santiago
les agradezco muchísimo que hayan estado
con nosotros en el programa hoy se nos
fue el tiempo volando obviamente este
tema tiene muchísimos puntos y aristas
para seguir analizando pero les
agradezco habernos puesto en perspectiva
para a todos aquellos que estamos fuera
de las fronteras mexicanas para entender
toda esta controversia un punto
importante en la política mexicana esta
decisión que van a tomar en torno esta
reforma electoral a los dos les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
el nombre del equipo técnico del
programa Les agradecemos su sintonía la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de mi compañero Luis Fernando Montes y
la producción de invitados estuvo a
cargo de Tania Herrera ustedes pueden
seguir dejando comentarios a través de
las redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]